oh gott oh gott leute bevor wir mit
diesem video an fachleute muss ich euch
waren die letzten die es auf diesem
kanal waren gut sie waren gut für den
kopf sie waren entspannt sie waren kein
crash das heutige video wird das ändern
nein alarmstufe rot ich habe eine serie
gefunden die allein von den storyline
cad auf den fans erkennbar sind
mindestens so schlimm wenn nicht sogar
schlimmer als hilf mir ist wenn wir uns
heute eine folge davon anschauen fangen
mit dem video an genauer gesagt geht es
um anwälte im einsatz die serie und das
video heißt mit 15 kilo hilfe mein sohn
15 hat was mit alte nachbarin
ich entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal
jetzt bei anwälte im einsatz
claudia bruns will ihren erst 15
jährigen jungen aus den fängen der
doppelt so alten nachbarin befreien
bernd römer kämpft für mutter und so
dafür braucht man keinen anwalt dafür
braucht man einfach einen vater oder
also ich denke ich warum man dafür jetzt
ein anwalt braucht also knows no front
an die serie noch front an alle leute
die 15-jährige söhne aus den klauen von
cougars mit hilfe von anwälten entfernen
wollen aber wer denkt sich so ist mein
sohn hat eine beziehung mit dazu alten
frau so ok anwalt
meine mutter macht sich sorgen die hat
auch eine summe gesicht das ist nur der
prämien ist schon wirklich zugeht steht
jetzt allen ernstes der anwalt in anzug
auf dem sportplatz und rede mit einem 15
jährigen jungen weil dieser von der
nachbarin angemacht wird an welt im
einsatz
der ist offensichtlich im einsatz hat er
ist nicht in seinem büro der muss im
einsatz sein
ja ja nein also ich warte mal nicht mal
witze ich hab grad eben schon wird dazu
gemacht sorry dafür sicherheiten falsch
verstanden
sensibles thema leute ich weiß ich
wollte nur noch mal an der stelle sagen
dass tatsächlich kein theater dem
haushalt ist also dann halt an der
anwalt haben
[Musik]
so müsse es sein das war geiler können
nicht aber so - integrieren solche
serien das würde die ganze angelegenheit
mit dem quintett ein bisschen
erleichtern
sie ruft einfach so gott oh gott leute
das erinnert mich jetzt wieder daran
warum ich den entschluss gefasst habe
mit tief mehr aufzuhören und warum die
letzten beiden videos für genossen habt
genau weil das mir wieder mein
denkvermögen zerstört außerdem muss ich
mich ganz entschieden gegen die annahme
werden das küssen auf den mund nicht zum
rasenmähen dazu gehören wer so was sagt
hat in seinem leben noch nie rasen
gemäht
ich habe einen fehler gemacht ich habe
die story schon wieder zu sehr für bare
münze genommen
wir müssen weitergehen wir müssen wieder
mal eigentlich die geschichte an sich
hinterfragen eigentlich ist das so also
ich mag deutschland sehr muss dazu sagen
deswegen ist das nicht in der
abwertenden richtung gemeint so richtige
ahlmann mentalität einfach so irgendwas
in meinem leben passt mir nicht
nee nee ich will jetzt ein anwalt ich
verlag jetzt irgendwie das wetter
gefällt mir heute nicht ich verklagt
jetzt ich verklage jetzt die tagesschau
weil die instrumente angesagt hat man
muss sozusagen der rasen hintergrund ist
nicht gemäht das ist ganz natürlich dass
schlechte cover up store ist nicht
wirklich gewählt leute oder es geht
schon wieder mit mir durch so rasen
mähen so als das war gestern bei meiner
freundin hat wieder den rasen gemäht
also noch zwei sachen dazu einer erster
stelle gesagt es ist genau diese
mentalität einfach so egal so ich habe
mir den zeh gestoßen jetzt verklage ich
den hersteller von meinem tisch und
zweitens muss jetzt an dieser stelle
sagen leute wie gesagt ich entschuldige
mich bei allen kunden stelle passiert
aber ich muss jetzt mal will sagen bei
dieser nachbarin hätte ich mit 15 jahren
auch rasen gemäht freundlichen warum man
alle 15 jährigen oder jüngeren die meine
videos schauen ihr seid auch junge nicht
gewachsen also ok pro ja du bist nicht 3
du bist aber auch nicht 25 sowie unter
stehst immer noch so der obhutspflicht
von deinen eltern zu die passende auf
die auf ist aber so dürr in meinem kopf
bin ich schon erwachsen und ich mähe den
rasen wo ich will wachsen
er hat wirklich gesagt naja okay du bist
du erwachsen mit 15 jahre ja ok ja mach
dein ding macht dein ding versucht mal
dir genauso zu kaufen oder so und
versucht mal den kaufvertrag tatsächlich
wirksam zu machen und über sich aber
dass im autohaus gießen sagst ja ich
will gerne auto kaufen ich bin aber
leider 15 und die dann sagen okay
verpiss dich du dann aber sagt ich bin
aber erwachsen
dann werden wir mit sicherheit denn wenn
du jetzt schon im in den einsprechern
zwischendrin gestört da was ist das denn
für level normalerweise jacob wie diese
serie funktionieren die abhandlung und
dann dazwischen hat ja so einschnitte wo
die darsteller was ein sprechen wie sie
die aktuelle situation kommentieren die
mutter gönnt ihrem sohn einfach nicht
mal die ein sprecher die studenten
handelt anwälte mainz ist wie drinnen
also einmal ein satire ok alles klar
aber du mein lieber nach der aktion
spricht jetzt hier kein o ton
der ganze scheiße draußen zwar voll
peinlich machen wir stehen jetzt da wo
jörg leute hassen wir nicht alle diesen
einen augenblick den wir alle kennen
wenn man einfach gerade so kurz davor
ist die nachbarin zu klären die doppelt
so alt ist wie man selbst jäger und gut
aussieht junge ist euch klar weil die
krass man da wind mit seinen freunden
ist klar
und dann kommt die mutter dazwischen und
ruiniert seine klassiker no joke du
verstehst es nicht ich war nur zum
rasenmähen da ich war kurz davor den
rasen zu mähen ich war auf meinem john
deere aufsitzrasenmäher schon drauf ich
war gerade dabei den ersten gang
einzulegen ja und in diesem moment
kommst du sollst du mäßig den rasen doch
ich hätte es gemacht hat leider nicht
ich war kurz davor den rasen zu mähen
wie gesagt wie es auch die ganze zeit
schon gesagt wurde dass er nun hört ja
ich schau dir diese sendung eigentlich
damit spielt schaut ihr das ja ich war
kurz davor ich habe auf meinem
aufsitzrasenmäher schon die scheinwerfer
an gemacht hab schon die schnitttiefe
eingestellt wenn ihr versteht was ich
hier meine meine lieben schwestern und
dann kam die mutter dazwischen nicht
kann was nicht rasen gemäht
du wartest du wolltest rasen mähen du
hast den rasen nicht komplett gemäht
also ich würde so erhält
das hat mir zwar keiner erzählt immer
die frauen hat es die ganze zeit also
okay nein jetzt ich muss jetzt meine
meinung ändern leute es ist also man
muss wirklich sagen es ist schon etwas
geisteskranke sehr großer teil
geisteskrank ist dabei wenn eine frau
von 30 jahren interesse romantisches
interesse an einem 15 jährigen kind hat
das irgendwie dieser kurze augenblick
leute wie wie seht ihr die serien
relation zu hilfe schreibt man das in
die kommentare reichen für euch
vorgeschlagenes video aber auch nicht um
einen kanal oder die nächste folge
anwälte im einsatz ist über euch und
mich weil ich euch verklagen weil ihm
ein kanal nicht abonniert haben